Penny Marshall has led an extraordinary
life from the streets of New York to the
Hollywood Hills and she'll admit that
it's all been well a little nuts this
morning Bill Whitaker looks back at her
hit filled career on both sides of the
camera it was a date with the Fonz on
happy days that started Penny Marshall
on her journey to the Hollywood a-list
Marshalls Laverne and Cindy Williams
Shirley were such a hit in primetime
they soon had a TV show of their own
Laverne and Shirley debuted on January
27th 1976 and by season three it was the
most-watched television show in America
after seven years on top
Marshalls friend Whoopi Goldberg
convinced her to move behind the camera
and antistick directing Goldberg in
jumping jack flash
her sophomore effort big turned out to
be huge and Marshall became the first
woman to direct a film that earned 100
million dollars at the box office it
also earned Tom Hanks his first Oscar
nomination Marshall went on to direct a
string of memorable film swimming
defined by both their humor and heart
for CBS this morning bill would occur in
Los Angeles Penny Marshall the title of
the book as my mother was nuts yes she
was not Stu so I know I was trying to
figure out a dignified way to ask but
after reading the book I'm thinking you
might be a little nutty to penny more
well I don't deny that huh yeah we're
all nuts
no you look back over your life because
you start out with this you had to not
much personal drama growing up with
parents who hated each other two
marriages divorces the ups and down of
various relationships raising a daughter
watching friends crack up and overdose
there was that cancer thing too but when
you look back over the body of your life
don't you think all in all it's turned
out okay for you absolutely I look not
this is a class I don't know what that
does but yes no I've been lucky life
yeah I think a lot of life is luck you
talk very candidly about your looks you
were in a commercial with Farrah Fawcett
there was a movie role where it said
then we're gonna go to the plane girl
doing something only girl a homely girl
homely girl that bar homely cruel it
were penny why do they write that I
don't know I don't know and but you talk
very candidly about how you were never
happy with the way that you look still
not I was gonna ask you at this age now
don't you feel haven't you gotten to the
place where you go this is who I am I'm
comfortable in my own skin or know I'm
all fat blue chubby here but you're on
Jenny Craig penny is there such a thing
as a good old days because you were
married to Rob Reiner and your house
seemed to be the place where everybody
came we were the stable couple if you
could imagine that no you say that I
mean the names nor that used to come to
her house talk about those days where
people he'd come over just to sort of
relax it penny out Brooks who was Rob's
best friend yeah Billy Crystal came over
Jim Brooks there were a lot of writers
Jerry Belson Harvey Miller you know who
had passed but you know Chuck Grodin I
mean whoever was around came over and
they'd be funny you write a lot about
the drugs well that was a seven
baby yeah and what around for one but
none of that now none of that no yeah no
I did it you you talk very candidly
about the drugs and then if that isn't
enough you get a brain tumor and cancer
yes and you point out that you're one of
the few people that actually gain weight
on chemotherapy most people lose 60
pounds yeah but you gain weight on and I
got hard nails yeah I know but penny
once that happens to you do you have a
moment where you go why why me did you
ever have that moment no I asked the
White Castle deal with tragedy where I
deal with bad things very calmly and
when I'm bored is when I'm in trouble
you talk about Tom Hanks and big which
by the way nor if it hadn't if it had
gone a different way Rob DeNiro would
have been in big I just can't even
imagine anybody other than Tom Hanks and
well no we want to talk Tom turned it
down everybody turned it down
so I said let me go another way and get
a man not a boy child yeah yeah yeah and
Bobby wanted to do a commercial film no
but Tom Hanks Oh Bob Tom Hanks writes
about you penny Marshall's a fascinating
woman who was led to like Donner that do
you know she gave me two of the best
jobs I've ever had of course not because
when she talks she's barely
comprehensible that's to read her memoir
and you'll come to love her as much as I
do
did you ever think about changing your
voice penny because you do have a very
distinct way of speaking well my father
sent me to the University of New Mexico
and my brother insisted to Northwestern
for all of us to use our Bronx accent it
didn't work yeah will you do another
movie I'd rather do television cuz it's
faster mhm don't do vampires I don't do
all right uncle car crashes they're
going to people in big metal suits so
there you go okay and we should say we
started the interview asking penny did
you want to wear your sunglasses and you
said yes are you sure you want to wear
them and you say yes and I'm not glaring
at my camera guys no
do this Penny Marshall the name of the
book is my mother was not since now on
sale please boy